on passe au sport même si nous étions
déjà un petit peu dans le sport avec le
billard sinon je vais vexer nos
précédents invités mais là on parle de
triathlon à présent
puisque ce week-end va avoir lieu le
premier championnat de France de cross
triathlon et pour en parler évidemment
l'un des organisateurs j'ai un hasard
bonsoir à vous bonsoir alors un premier
championnat de France de cross triathlon
en 2013 j'ai envie de dire ça arrive un
peu tard non alors c'est en plus
particulier puisqu'il y a déjà eu un
championnat du monde avant d'avoir un
championnat de France ou un championnat
de National en tout cas et 2011 qui
était en 2011 voilà en Espagne et donc
c'était juste une volonté de la
Fédération va développer cette pratique
qui est finalement
très nouvelle dans le dans la Fédération
il existe un label spécialisé là-dedans
mais dans la Fédération voilà il y avait
des triathlon vert et puis comme ça se
développe puisque c'est vraiment bien
bien apprécié ils ont lancé un la France
et alors les spécificités de ce cross
triathlon par rapport à un triathlon
classique donc que l'on connaît plutôt
bien maintenant voilà donc triathlon
classique natation vélo course à pied et
a priori tout se passe sur la route pour
le vélo et pour la course à pied là on
est sur un cross triathlon donc on est
en VTT et puis la partie course à pied
se passe en chemin également donc là on
voit des images de
Séville en 2011 et bah la partie course
à pied secours aussi là dedans dans
l'herbe dans la forêt ça veut dire que
c'est plus difficile qu'un triathlon
classique ça va être plus difficile
puisque voilà le VTT est quand même
demande plus d'efforts surtout que là on
va avoir ici énormément de dénivelé et
puis la course à pied avec les reprises
d'appui etc qui vont être différents que
sur route rend l'épreuve plus difficile
et donc du coup il va sûrement y avoir
une différence de temps à l'arrivée sur
la ligne d'arrivée j'imagine entre un
triathlon classique et un triathlon un
cross Triel là on va être effectivement
à peu près au niveau du double du simple
double donc on passe de un effort d'une
heure une heure cinq sur le sprint qu'on
organise à presque deux heures sur sur
cette épreuve donc ça veut dire aussi
une compétition plus difficile donc une
préparation différente en amont
justement
on n'utilise pas voilà les mêmes muscles
en tout cas déjà ne serait-ce que les
mêmes vélos et les mêmes chaussures pour
la pratique donc on va demander à un
entraînement spécifique certaines
personnes sont spécialisées là dedans et
ne font que du cross triathlon ça prouve
bien qu'il y a vraiment un entraînement
spécifique alors il y a quelques
exceptions qui vont exceller là dedans
mais on est sur quelque chose de
vraiment bien particulier et particulier
aussi en termes de tactique j'imagine
parce que la tactique de course est
toujours très primordiale donc triathlon
là comme dans le vélo habituellement on
peut se cacher derrière les adversaires
là c'est plus le cas on VTT exactement
alors on a le droit toujours de se
cacher ou d'être à l'abri comme on dit
mais l'effet va être moindre puisqu'il y
a moins de vitesse et puis pareil la
partie aussi natation va être nage moins
vite puisqu'on demande plus en vélo donc
voilà il y a un petit rééquilibre à
faire un réajustement à faire mais c'est
sûr qu'on est plus un effort solitaire
puisque il y a moins de d'effets
d'aspiration en vélo donc premier
championnat de France de cross triathlon
titre historique oui donc ça veut dire
qu'il va y avoir un beau plateau ce
weekend du côté de Versailles il va y
avoir effectivement quelques athlètes
bien bien renommés de la discipline et
donc on va avoir la chance d'avoir
quelques élites qui participent au
niveau international qui ont déjà
participé au championnats du monde aussi
en 2011 donc on va voir voilà un beau
plateau et on en est fier à côté des
Champions il y aura aussi des formules
un petit peu découvertes puisque vous
voulez aussi un peu populariser le sport
c'est ça voilà on a toujours cette
volonté de développer le triathlon
puisque on apparaît comme un sport
élitiste et difficile or c'est pas du
tout le cas puisque il suffit de juste
déplacer le curseur vers le bas pour se
faire plaisir en triathlon et pour
exemple l'année dernière on avait 1500
participants et 500 était non licenciés
donc on découvert totalement ce sport
chez nous et on a cette même volonté
pour cette année et sur cette édition là
vous êtes aussi en partenariat avec une
association qui aide les jeunes
handicapés je crois voilà exactement
c'est l'association d'un corps à l'autre
donc qui a fait une animation l'année
dernière pour montrer que c'était
possible de faire du triathlon en ayant
un handicap et cette année on refait la
même chose avec une animation donc
l'association d'un corps à l'autre qui
par le sport va aider les jeunes
handicapés à s'insérer et puis à faire
des activités très bien donc on se
retrouve tout le week-end le samedi pour
les épreuves hommes et femmes SX c'est
ça voilà alors le samedi il va y avoir
les épreuves s donc anciennement sprint
où on va avoir également un très gros
plateau avec notamment une de nos
sélectionnée olympique qui a participé
aux JO de l'année dernière et le
dimanche ça va être tout être en nature
avec le XS
donc pour tout le monde et voilà la
petite formule et le cross triathlon
pour pour les épices même s'il y a
quelques noms licenciés qui participent
d'ailleurs et donc le premier titre de
champion de France de cross triathlon